[Musique]
2023 c'est la 6e année d'existence de
l'incubateur de 50 ans en Yvelines le
ski cube et nous sommes avec le
directeur du ski cube Jean-Luc mélo
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors quel bilan faites-vous de ces six
années d'existence d'abord une belle
aventure c'est vrai que lorsqu'on a
ouvert ce site il y avait quelque part
une notion un peu d'expérimentation
puisque c'était nouveau pour le
territoire de Saint-Quentin et on se
rend compte que après 5 6 années
maintenant de l'activité qu'il a toute
son utilité et qui qui s'est doté de
riches d'expérience au bénéfice des
entreprises du territoire alors le
principe de l'incubateur c'est
d'accueillir des startups pour les faire
grandir les lancer comment quel bilan
vous faites en termes de chiffres
combien d'entreprises vous avez
accueilli alors des startups vous avez
raison puisque c'est quelque part la
vitrine du site avec notre incubateur
dont on parlera sans doute mais beaucoup
d'autres projets et de d'action porter à
destination des entreprises en création
d'entreprise d'une manière générale mais
également avec les entreprises en
activité principalement autour des des
ressources humaines et l'accompagnement
en termes de RH voilà donc beaucoup
beaucoup de d'activités et l'incubateur
pour terminer sur sur ce sujet là
l'incubateur avec plus d'une soixantaine
de start-up qu'on était et accompagné
durant ses premières années d'activité
on le voit derrière vous vous parlez de
l'accompagnement il y a plein de
rendez-vous on voit l'agenda derrière
vous du mois de janvier puis du mois de
février finalement c'est un
accompagnement global sur tous les
sujets qui peuvent concerner le
dirigeant d'entreprise oui tout à fait
voilà quel que soit la nature l'activité
quel que soit le stade d'avancement de
de projet de développement de
l'entreprise on essaie proposer de
l'accompagnement individuel collectif au
travers d'animation au travers de
formation à travers le rendez-vous la
mobilisation d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs économiques d'experts qui
viennent ici apporter leurs compétences
au service des entreprises voilà donc
c'est vraiment tout un écosystème qu'on
essaie de mobiliser pour que les
entreprises du territoire se développent
dans les meilleures conditions alors sur
les 60 entreprises il y en a encore
présent d'ailleurs on va rejoindre tout
à l'heure deux dirigeants de startups
qui sont actuellement en incubation une
en accélération
hostie cube est-ce que il y a des
histoires qui vous ont marqué des
success story économiques né ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on a
maintenant des entreprises effectivement
dont on est particulièrement fier vous
allez effectivement rencontrer
quelques-unes je pourrais en évoquer
d'autres comme l'Accord que
effectivement que vous avez déjà eu avec
lequel vous avez déjà eu l'occasion
d'échanger dans d'autres d'autres
contextes voilà des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui
trassent leur chemin mobilisent des
fonds arrivent à avoir une bonne
relation avec l'écosystème du territoire
et si je ne prends l'exemple que
l'accord c'est pour nous un exemple
qu'on cite souvent parce qu'il est eu un
cheminement au-delà de l'accompagnement
qu'on a pu lui proposer d'intégration
d'un écosystème puisqu'à termesse qui
est une très belle PME du territoire a
pris une participation dans dans cette
entreprise est aujourd'hui un acteur
capital sans une mot dans la dynamique
en tout cas dans le développement de
cette startup qu'on a eu plaisir
d'accompagner pendant quelques années
alors en 2016 il y avait uniquement
l'incubation c'est-à-dire un programme
d'incubation maintenant il y a un
programme d'accélération depuis l'année
dernière oui ça c'est effectivement
important puisque l'incubation
effectivement nous permet de prendre les
projets très en amont et puis de leur
permettre de se structurer pour se
lancer sur les premiers marchés alors
que l'accélération est plutôt dans une
phase avale où on recrute des startups
qui ont déjà un certain montant de
chiffre d'affaires et qui ont besoin de
le booster donc on est là effectivement
dans une phase plus avale pour permettre
à ces entreprises avec tous les moyens
dont on disposition de passer ce cap qui
est important et notamment ce câble des
premières années de développement
commercial donc ça c'était une nouveauté
sur les deux dernières années de notre
incubateur alors Jean-Luc dans les
prochaines semaines il y aura de
nouvelles startups qui vont intégrer le
ski cube quels sont les projets qui vont
être développés ici alors toujours dans
la double dynamique incubation
accélération dans la dynamique
accélération incubation puisqu'on va
commencer par la partie plutôt avale on
a par exemple une plateforme qui va se
développer avec notre accompagnement
pour aider les salariés de tous
entreprises à mieux déchiffrer leur
fiche de paye donc c'est une voilà
quelque chose de nouveau qu'on va
essayer d'accompagner très prochainement
et puis également dans le newspace donc
là aussi on a déjà un projet en
accélération que que l'on accompagne ici
dans la logique du Space et on un gros
projet qui va arriver ici mais un peu
plus en amont et donc ça fera partie des
deux projets qu'on a recrutés pour la
prochaine promo de d'incubation et en
accélération là aussi trois projets très
sympas avec voilà des thématiques très
diverses puisque c'est aussi la vocation
de ski cube de notre incubateur d'abord
une vocation très généraliste et sur les
thématiques qui correspondent aussi aux
filières qu'on entend booster sur le
territoire ou filière phare du
territoire et donc voilà trois projets
qu'on a qu'on a souhaité recruter et qui
vont être évidemment en phase avec la
stratégie de développement économique de
50 ans Yvelines l'avenir du ski cube ce
qu'il y a de d'autres programmes qui
vont être développés pour accompagner
encore plus les dirigeants d'entreprise
après quelques années on commence à
avoir une certaine notoriété dans
l'écosystème
saccléaire mais au-delà francilien et là
très prochainement on va répondre à un
appel à projet de la région pour être
labellisé avoir un label qui va qui va
être attribué un certain nombre
d'incubateurs franciliens donc on est
fier de pouvoir effectivement apporter
les couleurs de Saint-Quentin auprès de
la région on espère évidemment que ce
sera couronné de succès merci Jean-Luc
merci à vous